the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video
all right my friends in this video i
want to look back at one of the most
infamous episodes in television history
this is the episode known as the long
night
when the night king and his army arrived
in winterfell for the final showdown
now as you all know there were a lot of
different things that happened in this
episode that made some fans very happy
but there were also a lot of things that
made a lot of fans very angry
as a matter of fact you can still find
some of us debating these things several
years after the episode originally aired
now what i will be focusing on in this
video is this scene in which
jon snow faced off against viserion i'm
assuming most of you remember this scene
very well
it's when jon was running after the
night king in hopes of stopping him from
reaching the godswood where bran stark
was waiting
unfortunately jon never makes it to the
godswood before the night king gets
there because viserion lands right in
front of him
stopping him from moving any further now
john did make several attempts at
getting around him but as we all know
nothing worked the dragon would not
budge
this eventually leads to jon snow
standing up looking him in the eyes
then screaming in his face there has
been a big debate about this scene ever
since
there were a lot of fans who actually
thought jon snow did that because he
wanted to distract
vasarion so arya could make it to the
godswood to get the night king herself
those same fans thought jon was
screaming at arya to run
but that's not what happened then there
were some other fans who said
jon did this because he actually thought
this would help do something to the
dragon
as if jon actually thought that
screaming at the dragon would hurt it in
some way
now i don't know about you but that
might be one of the dumbest things i've
ever heard
i wish i was making it up but there were
a large number of fans who really
thought that
i actually think i have the right answer
the reason why i want to share this
is because i still see fans discussing
this scene in some of the facebook
groups
i haven't seen anyone else look at this
scene the same way that i do
now normally i would not say something
like this but in this case
i believe almost everyone is looking at
this scene the wrong way
now let me explain why i think jon snow
screamed in viserion's face
the first thing we need to do is go back
and look at where this scene actually
started
what really set this in motion is when
jon and the night king had their final
face-to-face meeting
if you remember this was right after
daenerys set the night king on fire with
drogon
after daenerys realized it did not work
the night king grabbed another spear
then daenerys flew off leaving jon snow
there to face the night king
unfortunately we did not see them fight
one versus one
this is when the night king did what he
always does he lifted his arms
raising the dead all around john as soon
as jon was surrounded
the night king walked off heading
directly for the godswood
now in that moment jon knew he was
screwed
not only was he now surrounded by
hundreds if not thousands of whites
but the night king essentially had a
direct line for the godswood
jon knew that he had to work as fast as
he could if he was going to save
everyone
he knew he could not allow the night
king to get to the godswood before he
did
that was when the desperation really set
in because he could see the night king
heading that way
he knew the night king would be in the
godswood in the matter of moments
now luckily for jon danny did not go far
she doubled back
and burned a lot of the whites who were
stopping jon from moving forward
as soon as she did that jon looked at
her and yelled bran
then dany yelled go because she also
knew that the night king was heading
that way
fast as jon makes his way through
winterfell fighting off the dead one by
one
this is where we really saw how
desperate he was this is when jon
finally made it inside winterfell's
courtyard
leaving him only about a hundred yards
away from the night king
and ultimately bran all jon had to do
now
was make it to the other side he knew
the night king already had a good head
start
but that wasn't the biggest issue in
that moment jon also knew that the night
king would not be getting slowed down
like he was
because the whites were obviously all on
the night king's side
that only left jon with minutes or maybe
even only seconds to make it through all
of the madness before the night king
reached bran
john knew for every second he was slowed
down that was another second closer the
night king was to finishing his
mission now as jon made his way across
winterfell
he saw his best friend samwell being
overran by all the whites
he could see that sam was about to die
but he knew that he could not stop for
even one second to help his friend
john knew in that moment he might have
to sacrifice
everyone in that courtyard if it meant
stopping the night king before he got
bran
every one of the main characters who
were there were fighting off several
wipes during that scene
it looked as if all was about to be lost
jaime lannister was about to die
gendry and berean was about to die even
daenerys who was now no longer on her
dragon
was about to die alongside jorah mormont
in that moment
it seemed as if jon was the only hope
after all he was the only one that was
moving forward
right on the heels of the night king
however if he doesn't make it across
that courtyard
everyone he knew and loved would be dead
all of that was running through jon's
mind in that scene
this is why he was fighting with every
ounce of energy he had
he would stop at nothing and right when
it looked like he was about to make it
one of the final bosses lands directly
in front of him
viserion was not about to let him make
another step further
that's when jon knew if he doesn't get
around that damn dragon right away
it's game over now jon did make several
attempts at sneaking around viserion but
the dragon doesn't let him go
jon had to fall back over and over again
this is when it starts to sink in with
jon he's not gonna make it
and as a matter of fact he knows the
night king is most likely already there
he did have a head start after all and
jon has now been held down by that
dragon for far too long
i mean look at john in that moment he's
bleeding all over his body
he has been weakened by all of the
fighting he was absolutely exhausted
and he now realizes he cannot and will
not make it around the damn dragon
even though he can see the finish line
right on the other side of the dragon
he knows he's never gonna get there the
night king has most likely made it to
the godswood already
and not only that but jon might even be
thinking bran is already dead
this is when jon accepts his fate this
is when he stands up and screams in
viserion's face
now this is when a lot of fans thought
why would jon do that
how would that help him get to the night
king any faster it doesn't make any
sense
well my friends that is the look of
defeat
when jon stands up and screams in the
face of the dragon
that is him letting out all of his
frustration he is letting out all of his
anger
all of that pain and exhaustion all of
those years
everyone looked down on him because he
was a bastard
he is thinking about everything that has
happened to him and his family
he's thinking about all of the years he
served in the night's watch
all of that work he did to band everyone
together to fight in this moment
all of those sacrifices he made to
hopefully save the realm
i mean he already died once because he
was trying to help everyone win this
inevitable battle against the night king
and after all of that it would still not
be enough in the end
he was only a few feet away but after
everything he had done to ensure they
would be successful in that moment
it unfortunately was not enough i see
that scene
as an emotional breakdown jon knew it
was over
but if he was about to die then he would
die standing on his feet
now although i really wished it was jon
who fought the night king in the end
i still thought this was a great moment
if you look at it the way that i do
let me know what you think about this
scene do you agree with me
or do you think something else was
happening here leave me all of your
thoughts down below
i would love to see what you have to say
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching the video
i hope you all have a great day i will
see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
you